yeah okay a bit of a late start to this
game welcome to this video
yeah right when I had the game poppin up
I had the doorbell ringing got something
delivered so playing Sheila what is he
doing
got something delivered as well you
never know
okay so let's see it's gonna play the
Petrosian quite a good impression of the
positions that I was getting when I
tried this out recently and curious how
I'm faring here I wonder if he can play
no oh that's a five here
so I can do this right
I thought that would cost too much time
but okay we'll see what happens okay the
night on a six can be an off side piece
but this is lots of time and I've got c5
coming up and if c5 hits
that's not to be underestimated he has
played a5 which weakens some squares
there so we'll see what happens but I
mean generally quite happy with this
position go c5 prepare Knights you form
okay so he just gives up g6 or what
exactly is going on so if I take it
what's what happens
d6 is a pretty important corner
Wow Wow
so for example if I take f6 rook chicks
and he allows them to take on c7 really
okay what is the what is the big point
now what is the big point probably take
with the look like a for all and then no
I thought that maybe if for then Bishop
g7 that could have worked actually maybe
that that could have worked okay anyway
if I take now here you form can also
take play Knight b6 or what a mess what
a friggin mess okay let's take it yeah
so I have got 96 now and then
potentially just promote okay if I just
move the bishop does he have anything
great
Bishop g7 I can play Knight d6 en
disposition but Queen a7 is probably a
queen a5 between 8 7
threatening queen-to-be
8 now which she does not react you queen
bee aide and then 96 was my thing my
thinking queen bee ain't and ninety-six
isn't that winning her checking okay
let's play it
I wonder what I'm missing here or maybe
I'm not missing something with some
miracle defense
my background is weak but at least
everyone discovered [ __ ] eight comes
another 96
and it all comes with tempo so I would
be really amazed if that isn't a win
check check
black forfeits due to this connection
okay so kind of typical so let's let's
have a look there I don't don't don't
quite don't quite get some things him
you know this this feels very slowish
but I was really amazed that he just
would give up after this just give up
everything here I mean you you have
still have normal moves that you can
play and this just just losers right and
it just loses gives up gives up the most
important porn in the position for for
nothing basically
this winter yeah but I wonder if I did
it right because he had this Bishop g7
this okay yeah this year if I move the
bishop Bishop g7 I have rookie one
though yeah this is extremely important
I did I didn't anticipate this that I
have to play this move so that was luck
him yeah that's really really no way out
I guess and couldn't be 8c on said you
just gave away the six for no particular
reason I mean you can can still play
normal moves okay guys thanks for
watching
identically killer analysis you haven't
basically told you what happened thanks
for watching